hi I'm Eric Watson Benham has arrived
and yes there is a lot to talk about
this Tom Hardy Inc Hulk symbiote
cannibal buddy comedy but let's start
with the real reason we see these movies
keeping the theater usher is late by
obsessing over the post-credits scenes
then I'm had two scenes to play it after
the movie and in this video I'm gonna
break down both of them and explain some
interesting details that you might have
overlooked in case you haven't seen
venom yet huge spoiler warning go watch
this movie okay let's start with the
first post-credits scene Eddie Brock
continues with his life as America's
only growing journalist don't let vice
news fool you journalists or nerds but
now Eddie has a buddy joining him on his
quest to win the Pulitzer for sexiest
man alive I guess Venom symbiote and he
rolls up to San Quentin prison telling
venom this is a me thing not a we thing
and the prison guard says that the
inmate Eddie's visiting requested Eddie
to interview him and Eddie says the FBI
probably just wanted to send mate to
help identify bodies and then we meet
this prisoner who's in deep lockup whom
the guard calls red yes this is cletus
kasady played by Woody Harrelson
Cassidy becomes the carnage symbiote an
offspring of the Venom symbiote in the
comics Eddie Brock shares a prison cell
with Cassidy a man who is already a
sadistic serial killer at this point in
his life he kills its grandmother he
burned down his orphanage he tortured a
dog with a drill yeah I'm done with this
guy Eddie's symbiote passes on to
Cassidy who upon getting out of prison
takes on the offspring of carnage and he
goes on a savage killing spree that
makes venom look like a Boy Scout or
just a typical nerdy journalist we
already see glimpses of that violence
here where Cassidy has smeared what
looks like blood on the cell walls right
in welcome Eddie woody wearing the same
curly red hair that Cassidy does in the
comics asks to forego the typical serial
killer quotes for example the Dadaist
patterns of arterial spray mocking the
way some pop culture serial killers see
blood spatter as art looking at you
Dexter
and clearly not wanting to hit the nail
too on the head Cletus Kasady promises
that when he gets out of prison there's
gonna be carnage yeah part of me was
hoping he was gonna say yeah get out of
here there's gonna be dr. often
clearly Sony is using this post credit
scene to set up a sequel which the Venom
symbiote fights the carnage symbiote
which to do justice will probably need
to be r-rated and honestly it's really
the kind of story I wanted this been a
movie to be but the question is is this
the moment in which Cassidy acquires the
symbiote offspring from Eddie Brock does
some of Cassidy's blood drip off that
nice welcome sign-on to Eddie it's a
noun fused with his symbiote and then
split off into carnage maybe this
encounter between Brock and Cassidy is
just the first of a series of interview
sessions one of which will later feature
the famous fluid swap it's also
interesting - Cassidy requested Brock
specifically so I think we can assume he
knows about Eddie's symbiote and he has
some plan to get his own inner inked
Hulk the revealed carnage was the big
moment venom fans were hoping to see but
interestingly I think the second
post-credit scene got me more excited
for the future of this Sony spider-verse
an exclusive clip from the upcoming
animated movie spider-man into the
spider verse okay so my breakdown of
that in just a second but first I want
to tell you about how this channel is
expanding to a new platform where you
can watch us do our thing in the best
possible format it's called scenery for
the first time ever you'll be able to
watch something with new rock stars
while we break it down senior it's a
chrome extension when you stream content
on your computer it lets you open up
real-time video commentary so we can
point out all the interesting details
that you missed as they come up in the
movie or TV show that you're watching
that way we're watching along with you
and scene are something that you can
participate in to senior lets you give
your take on the show's movies you love
to watch by synching your reaction
videos alongside what you're watching in
the same browser with scenery you can
create share and watch video commentary
synchronized with streaming shows movies
and clips from Netflix Hulu and YouTube
just go to see nerdcon slash new rock
stars on your desktop computer to watch
with us actually on our new rockstars
channel you can watch my commentaries on
Black Panther and Doctor Strange and
there's lots of other stuff there to see
her it's time to make a scene check it
out okay let's take a look at that
second post-credit scene the exclusive
clip for spider-man into the spider
verse this is an animated movie coming
out in December following Miles Morales
a kid from Brooklyn who takes over the
spider-man name in the Ultimate Comics
just in case you aren't familiar there
are multiple iterations of spider-man
throughout the Marvel Comics it's a
broad universe called the spider verse
actually this movie just released a big
trailer so go check out my breakdown of
all the Easter eggs in that but this
clip is new it opens with the words
meanwhile in another universe and we see
spider-man Miles Morales voiced by
shameik Moore running from a villain
called the Prowler who is actually his
uncle Aaron Aaron Davis Donald Glover
played Aaron Davis in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and spider-man
homecoming here he's voiced by Maher
Shula Aly Myles barely escapes any
visits a snowy Cemetery and he looks
over the grave of Peter Parker so here's
the deal in these comics Myles takes
over spider-man after Peter Parker dies
Myles says I'm sorry mr. Parker I wanted
to do what you asked I really do but I
can't do this without you perhaps
referring to some kind of dying wish
from Peter Parker for miles to take over
this legacy but then Peter Parker
actually shows up beside miles very
confused well that's kind of what this
movies all about Marvel bad guy Wilson
Fisk
kingpin used as a Hadron Collider to
open up some kind of wormhole that
causes several spider-man universes to
merge so this is a Peter Parker from his
normal universe where he hasn't died and
apparently he becomes homeless by the
way this movie will also feature Spider
Guin where Gwen Stacy becomes a Spider
Woman in a reality where Peter Parker
becomes the lizard there's also a Spider
Man more boys by Nic Cage where a Spider
Man is a darker and more style vigilante
penny Parker and anime Spider spin-off
who pilots espy sauce - dr mick robot
and spider-ham voiced by john mulaney a
spider that was bitten by a radioactive
pig and becomes a pig with spider-man
powers look I know it's silly that's
kind of the point anyway in miles is
shocked he accidentally knocks out Peter
and he gets spotted by guards but he
gets Webb to Peter so he has a hoist and
unconscious Peter over his shoulder you
know looking like a kid moving a body in
a graveyard
look this leads to an awesome animated
chase sequence with Miles and sleepy
Pete getting stuck to a speeding train
and smacking against the hoods of cars
in traffic we hear a police dispatcher
over the radio describing a child
dressed like spider-man dragging a
homeless corpse behind a train really
this clip is showing off into the spider
versus unique animation style
described by the creative team as a
living painting like walking into a
comic book with visible action line to
action words comic book framing even
printer ink dots this movie is being
produced by Lord and Miller the same
guys behind the lego movie so I think we
can expect a similar meta
tangible animation adventure which Sony
verse movie are you more looking forward
to into the spider verse or a venom and
carnage sequel comment down below with
your thoughts or follow me on twitter
and instagram at a box subscribe to this
channel for these kind of in-depth
breakdowns of all the stuff you love and
explanations of that which scares and
confuses you and apologies to david
Farenthold of the washington post for
serving as our go-to nerdy journalists
we need your nerd skills now more than
ever sir don't feel too bad because one
of these days it's gonna be
[Applause]
[Music]